We've been spending a lot of time outside by the pool,
and I realized that we ran out of sunscreen,
but asked lucky to make me some.
We all burn pretty easily,
so we went with something with a little bit more SPF.
He started by adding some coconut into his bowl.
He's a baker, so he makes sure that everything is very precise
before moving on to adding some beeswax,
shea butter, and also some cocoa butter.
Once all of that was combined in the bowl,
he added some jojoba oil as well.
He then filled a pot with some water before placing it on the stove,
letting it come to a boil,
and placing the glass bowl on top of that,
he continuously stirred until everything was melted and combined.
Once it was taken off the heat,
he added some zinc oxide powder to that
before whisking that all together for about a minute,
just making sure that's all coming together.
Once everything was combined,
he transferred it over to a glass jar
before closing that and popping that in the fridge to solidify.
About an hour later, it was all solid and ready to apply.
This went on so smooth and didn't leave a white cast on.